so good morning everyone so I'm going to
talk about some of the core methods in
deep reinforcement learning so the aim
of this talk is as follows first I'll do
a brief introduction to what deep RL is
and whether it might make sense to apply
it in your problem I'll talk about some
of the core techniques so there on the
one hand we have the policy gradient
methods then on the other hand we have
methods that learn a cue function
including cue learning and sarsa and
I'll talk a little at the end about what
are the pros and cons of these different
methods so first what is reinforcement
learning it's a branch of machine
learning consider concerned with taking
sequences of actions so often it's
described in terms of an age and inter
interacting with the previously unknown
environment and it's trying to maximize
some kind of cumulative reward some kind
of reward function that we've defined
accumulated over time and pretty much
any kind of task where you have some
kind of goal that you want to achieve
can be stated in these terms so this is
an extremely general formulation what's
deep reinforcement learning it's pretty
simple it's just reinforcement learning
where you're using neural networks as
function approximator x' so the
interesting thing about reinforcement
learning in contrast to supervised
learning is it's actually not totally
obvious what you should use your neural
network to approximate in reinforcement
learning and there are different kinds
of algorithms that approximate different
things so one choice is to use the
neural network to approximate your
policy which is how the agent chooses
its actions another choice is to
approximate the value functions which
measure how good or bad different states
are or have or actions and last you can
use the you can try to learn a model of
the system a dynamics model which will
make predictions about neck
States and rewards okay so I'll now give
a few examples of different different
places where you might apply
reinforcement learning and what the
observations and actions would be so one
example is robotics so here you could
imagine a robot where the observations
are the camera images and the joint
angles of the robot the actions are the
joint torques you're applying and the
reward is going to depend on what you
want the robot to do so so this is
something we as the algorithm designer
get to define so the rewards could be to
stay balanced to navigate to some target
location or something more abstract like
serve and protect humans so
reinforcement learning has also been
used in a lot of more practical
applications
well applications that have been
practical in the past I think robotics
will be very practical in the future but
for example when a one area is inventory
management so this is just one example
of how you could use reinforcement
learning for a decision making problem
so you you have to decide how much to
stock up on of every item and your
observations would be your current
inventory levels actions would be how
much of each item you're going to
purchase and reward is your profit so
people in operations research this is
this is a subfield study this kind of
problem a lot ok there are also a lot of
machine learning problems where people
have started to apply reinforcement
learning techniques so one example is
attention so the idea and attention is
you don't want to look at the whole
input at once you want to just focus on
part of it so one example of this is
with a large image you might want to
just crop out part of it and use that
and just do detection on that part of
the image so
here your observation would be your
current image window action is where to
look or where to crop your image and
reward is your whether you make a
classification error or not
so here the actions are trying to here
you have to try to choose the right area
of the image to look at so you'll do the
correct classification reinforcement
learning has also been used in
structured prediction problems which
having which in the past often weren't
considered to be reinforcement learning
problems but it turns out that like to
actually properly solve them it actually
is a reinforcement learning problem so
machine translation for example you so
you get a sort a sentence in the source
language and you have to admit a
sentence in this target language and you
can hear your observations are the
sentence in the source language you're
omitting one word at a time in the
target language and you have some reward
function that looks at the whole
sentence and tells you how good your
translation was so since this is non
differentiable and it's you yeah you
can't just like differentiate through
the whole thing and do gradient descent
so it turns out you have to do you can
use a policy gradient method to optimize
your translation system so people have
started to do that ok so that's just
those are just a few examples not
exhaustive at all but I just want to
since I just want to say a little bit
about how reinforcement learning fits
into the fits into the picture of all
the other types of machine learning
problems so previous I mean previous
courses in this series have talked about
supervised learning and supervised
learning so how does reinforcement
learning relate to them how is it
different so let's just first compare it
to let's look at supervised learning so
in supervised learning first the
environment samples and input/output
pair from some distribution row
the agent makes a prediction y hat using
its function f and it receives some loss
which tells it if it made the right
prediction of the wrong prediction so
the interpretation is environment ask
the agent a question and then tells her
the right answer so contextual bandits
are make this problem a little harder in
that they give the learning agent a
little bit less information so now the
environment samples and input but notice
that there's not a correct output
associated with it then the agent takes
an action and the agent receives some
cost which is from some probability
distribution so here C is the cost we're
sampling it from some probability
distribution and the agent doesn't know
what this probability distribution is so
that's what makes the problem hard so
environment ask the agent a question the
agent answers and the environment gives
you a noisy score on the answer so this
is applied this actually has a lot of
applications so personalized
recommendations is one big one along
with advertising so you have to decide
like customers who like this
I mean you for you have a customer and
you know what they liked in the past so
you have to make a prediction about what
they're going to like in the future so
you show them appropriate ads or links
like what either
like what ad what book you want to try
to advertise to them or what video you
want to show them and so on so here you
can the big difference between this and
the supervised learning setting is you
don't have access to the function the
loss function you're trying to optimize
so in particular you can't differentiate
through it we don't know the process
that generates C so we can't compute the
gradient of a loss function and use that
to tune the agents parameters so that
makes it so that makes the problem a bit
harder or you have to use a different
kind of algorithm
lastly reinforcement learning is almost
the same as the contextual
and it's setting except now the
environment is stateful so now instead
of sampling the initial state from
scratch every time step from the same
distribution the state evolves over time
so you have some transition probability
distribution called P here where the the
state X sub T is conditioned on the
previous state and the previous action
and that makes the problem quite a bit
harder because now well for a number of
reasons for one thing the inputs you're
getting depends on what actions you're
taking so now that makes it harder to
develop a stable reliable algorithm
because now as the agent starts to learn
it gets different inputs so that can
lead to all sorts of out-of-control
behavior and it also means you have
delayed effects because since the system
is stateful you might need to take a lot
of actions to get into the right State
so you might need to
you can't just act greedily every time
step you have to you have to think ahead
effectively okay so just to summarize
these differences there are two
differences the first one is you don't
have full analytic access to the
function you're trying to optimize you
have to query it through interaction
second you're interacting with a
stateful world which means that the
input you get is going to depend on your
previous actions and if you just take
the first of those differences between
supervised learning and reinforcement
learning you get the contextual bandit
setting so that's sort of halfway in
between okay so I realized that there
multiple this audience probably has
people with different interests some
people are doing research and want to
know about what's the latest in the
research world and some people are want
to apply these machine learning
techniques to practical applications so
this slide is for the latter group of
people so if you're wondering if you
have some problem where you think
reinforcement learning might be relevant
and you're one
if you should apply reinforcement
learning so first I should say that the
answer might be no it might be overkill
especially deep reinforcement learning
so this is a set of fairly new
techniques where it's not going to work
out of the box very well and it's these
techniques aren't that well established
so they require a lot of they have a lot
of knobs to be tuned so it might be
overkill and yeah these techniques
aren't that well established at the
moment so it might be worth
investigating some other methods first
so one one so if your problem has a
small number of parameters you're trying
to optimize over and you have a
simulator that you can like just do lots
of experiments on then derivative free
optimization methods are likely to be
better than reinforcement learning or
they're likely to be easier to get
working so these methods just look at
they just you give them a black box
function where you put in a parameter
vector and it'll give you a noisy
estimate of the score and these
algorithms will just optimize over the
parameters of that black box I mean that
are being put into that black box so
yeah there's a variety of different
methods for derivative free optimization
but these are easier to understand than
reinforcement learning and they do kind
of work out of the box okay a lot of
problems are actually can be seen as
content are contextual bandit problems
and the statefulness of the world isn't
that relevant so for example in
advertising this is where people people
look at advertising as a contextual
bandit problem most of the time because
you decide what ad to present the user
with and then they either click on it or
they don't but it's really the user is
kind of stateful because if you show
them a terrible ad they might just go
and download adblock so there is like
your actions do have some repercussions
but often you can just approximate it as
being a contextual bandit problem where
there is no
so there's a better theoretical
understanding of contextual bandit
problems and methods that are that have
some guarantees so in that case so if it
is a contextual bandit problem you might
want to use those kind of algorithms
instead and lastly the operations
research field has been using these
methods for a while and real problems
and they have a set of methods which are
just pretty much the basic algorithms
policy iteration and value iteration but
they're sort of well they're well
developed ways of doing feature
engineering for these problems that end
up working pretty decently so these
techniques are also worth considering
instead of trying to throw a big neural
network at it okay so now well now that
I've talked about what why not to use
deep reinforcement learning or what it's
not good for I'll just talk about some
recent success stories and deep
reinforcement learning which are
achievements that probably wouldn't have
been possible using these other
techniques so a few years ago there is a
pretty influential result by many at all
from deep mind where they used a deep
queue learning algorithm to play Atari
games using the screen images as input
and that's hard because you have these
get these games or you're trying to do
different things in all these games and
there some of them are kind of
complicated so it's pretty remarkable
that you can just use a simple but a
simple algorithm can solve them all this
the same algorithm can solve them all so
since then people have also solved or
solved this domain using policy
gradients and another algorithm called
dagger so another big groundbreaking
result was beating a champion level
player at go also by deep mind using a
combination of supervised learning from
like from
expert games plus policy gradients to
fine tune the supervised learning policy
plus Monte Carlo tree search plus value
functions to make the search work better
so a combination of techniques in
reinforcement learning robotic so some
of my colleagues at Berkeley had some
very nice results learning in real time
how to do manipulation tasks using an
algorithm called guided policy search
using the pr2 robot and some of my
colleagues and I have been working on
robotic locomotion using policy gradient
methods and people have been working on
locomotion for a while and have been
able to achieve pretty good results
using very like highly engineered
domain-specific methods but previously
there hadn't been much success using
general methods to solve it and last
there have been some recent results
playing 3d games using policy gradients
in fact there is even a contest I heard
about a couple days ago with this new
viz Doom task which is pretty nice so
you might want to check out visit to
meeeee ok so that's that's it for the
high level overview part of this now I'm
going to start getting into the actual
formalism and the technical details ok
so the basic object in the field of
reinforcement learning is the Markov
decision process so the Markov decision
process is defined by the following
components you have a state space this
is all the different states of the
system the action space these are all
the actions the agent can take and you
have this probability distribution which
which determines the probability of next
state and reward so R is the reward s
prime is the next state SN a are the
actions so it's a conditional
probability distribution sometimes
people
let this out into a separate reward
function but that's basically an
equivalent formulation okay and
sometimes there's some extra objects to
find it we'll be interested in the will
consider in it an initial state
distribution so this is on the world
starts out in a certain state and the
typical optimization problem you want to
solve given this MDP is to maximize
expected cumulative reward though there
are various ways of defining that more
precisely which I'll go into later ok so
there are various different settings of
reinforcement learning where you define
a slightly different optimization
problem the one will be most concerned
with is called the episodic setting so
here the agents experience is split up
into a series of episodes which have
finite length so in each episode we
first sample the initial state of the
world from some probability distribution
view and then the agent keeps on acting
until the world ends up in some terminal
state so just to give an example of what
terminal States might be like and how an
episode episode ik reinforcement
learning problem might look so one
example is when termination is good and
you want to terminate the episode as
fast as possible so if we imagine
setting up a task with some kind of taxi
robot that should get to the destination
as fast as possible then the episode
would be like one trip and its terminate
it's trying to terminate the episode as
fast as possible another example is a
waiter robot where you have a fixed
length shift but the waiter has to
accumulate it has to do as well as
possible during that shift so there the
episode has a fixed length the waiter
has to say maximize tips or a customer
happiness and then you could imagine
another kind of task where termination
is bad and you want the episode to last
as long as
possible so you can view life as an
example of that but also you could
imagine having a walking robot where you
want it to walk as far as possible
before it falls over and in this setting
it's pretty easy to find to define what
the goal is - we just want to maximize
the expectation of the total reward per
episode okay and the last object we're
going to introduce here is a policy so
the policy is just the function that the
agent uses to choose its actions so we
have deterministic policies which are
just the policy is denoted by PI so we
have the action is just some function of
the state and we also have stochastic
policies where the policy is a
conditional probability distribution so
here is just we're just going to make a
little bit more precise on the setting
of the episodic MVP so first we sample
the initial state from this distribution
mu then we then we get we sample the
first action from the policy a zero from
the policy then we sample next state and
reward from the transition probability
distribution and so on until we reach a
terminal state S sub T and then the
quantity we care about is the sum of all
these rewards are 0 plus R 1 dot plus R
sub t minus 1 and we want to maximize
yet so ADA is ADA of Pi is just defined
as the expected total reward of the
policy PI here's the picture that
illustrates exactly the same thing so
you can look at it as a graphical model
ok and lastly in the policy gradient
section in particular we're going to be
interested in parameterised policies so
here we have a parameter vector theta
which specifies which specifies exactly
what the policy is
so for
sample the family of policies could be
just a neural net we you have a certain
neural network architecture and theta
specifies all the weights of this neural
network so we could have a deterministic
policy of course or stochastic policy
and if you're wondering like concretely
what where the policy look like I mean
how do you use a neural network to
represent your policy it's actually
exactly you do exactly the same thing
you would do if this were a
classification or a regression problem
so in so s here the state here is your
input and the action is your output so
if you have a discrete action space a
discrete set of actions then you would
use a network that outputs a vector of
probabilities the probabilities of the
different actions this is exactly like a
classifier and if you have a continuous
action space your you would have your
neural network output the mean and the
diagonal of a covariance matrix of a
Gaussian distribution so this is just
like you're doing regression so you can
use the same kind of architectures you'd
use in supervised learning okay so
that's that's just the that's it for the
formalism of MVPs so now I'm going to go
into policy gradient methods which are
one broad and general class of
reinforcement learning methods which are
quite effective so to give a brief
overview of this here's here's the
intuition of what policy gradient
methods are going to do so here capital
R means the sum of rewards of the whole
episode so our optimization problem is
we want to maximize the expectation of
the total reward given our parameterised
policy PI sub theta and the intuition of
how our algorithm is going to work is we
we're going to collect a bunch of
trajectories I mean this is just run a
bunch of episodes using our policy and
then we want to make the good
trajectories more probable so I mean
some of the edge
trees were lucky and they were really
good some of them the agent was unlucky
and they are bad and the good the ones
that were good meaning there was high
reward that means the agent probably
took good actions there so we want to
increase the probability of the actions
from those trajectories so so the most
basic version of policy gradient methods
just try to make the good trajectories
more probable without trying to figure
out which were the good actions in which
were the bad actions slightly better
methods or more elaborate methods try to
figure out which actions were good and
which ones are bad and then they try to
make the good actions more probable and
lastly there's another class of methods
which which actually try to push the
actions towards better actions so they
differentiate the loss function with
respect to the actions and they try to
push the actions to better actions so
we're mostly going to talk about 1 & 2
here oh there's a question oh yeah good
questions so well we're maximizing over
the policy we're trying to find the best
policy but here the policy is assumed to
be parametrized so there's some
parameter vector theta that specifies
the policy and now we just want to
maximize with respect to theta any other
questions ok so there's a very very
fundamental fundamental concept which is
called the score function grading
estimator which underlies policy grading
methods so actually to introduce this
we're not going to talk about policies
in RL at all we're just going to assume
we have some expectation we have
expectation of f of X where X is sampled
from some parametrized probability
distribution so we want to compute the
grading of this expectation with respect
to theta so there's a general formula
that will do this and the way you derive
it is you just write the expectation as
an integral
and then you just move some things
around you swap the integral with the
derivative and you you turn it back into
an expectation and what you get at the
end is this bottom line which says that
you take the expectation of function
value times grad log probability so the
this is an unbiased estimator of the
gradient meaning if we get enough
samples it'll converge on the right
thing so the way you can compute this
estimator meaning the way you can get a
noisy estimate of the grading of the
expectation is you just collect one you
just get one sample from this
distribution and then you compute then
you multiply f of X times grad log
probability so the only requirement for
being able to use this estimator is we
need to be able to compute the
probability density I mean we need to be
able to analytically compute it and we
need to be able to differentiate it with
respect to theta and often it needs to
be differentiable there's another way of
deriving it using important sampling so
you write down the important sampling
estimator for the expectation and then
you just swap the derivative with the
expectation and you get the same thing
okay so so now let me just give a little
bit of intuition about this estimator
okay so f of X is measuring how good the
sample X is so that means that so G hat
here is our grading estimator meaning
this is what we get if we take one
sample X sub I and we compute our
estimator this is our estimate of the
gradient so if we move in Direction G
hat that pushes up the log probability
of our sample X sub I in proportion to
how good it is so if we have really good
if we got a really good function value
then we're going to try to push up its
log probability a lot and if it was a
bad function value then we're not going
to
try to push it up very much so pretty
simple intuition the really nice thing
is this is valid even if f of X is
discontinuous or if f of X is unknown
meaning you only you don't get to
differentiate it you just get to see the
function values or the sample space is a
discrete set so X doesn't even have to
be continuous and this is quite this is
quite remarkable actually that you don't
even need to have access to the full you
don't need to know exactly what the
function is that you're optimizing you
just have to be able to query it for the
function value and this means this is a
way of being able to differentiate
functions through a system that has non
differentiable pieces so for example in
in robotic locomotion one issue is that
you have contacts between the robot's
foot and the ground and contact you make
and break contact and that causes a
discontinuous change in the dynamics so
that makes it really hard to do smooth
optimization techniques to come up with
the right behavior so when you use this
kind of grading estimator along with
policy gradients which I'm going to talk
about very soon you can actually just
differentiate you can optimize the
system even though it has differentiable
pieces in it okay so okay so here's
another little picture of what's going
on so we have our function f of X which
we're trying to maximize the expectation
of and then we have our probability
that's the DP of X so we just sample a
bunch of values from our probability
density those are the blue dots on the x
axis and then we so then we we look at
the function values and we're trying to
push the probability distribution so
that the probability goes up at these
samples in proportion to the function
value so over on the right
side of the curve that means we're
trying to push that probability value up
really hard and on the left side we're
pushing it up softly so what's going to
happen is the probability density is
going to slide to the right if you can
imagine a sort of physical analogy there
okay so that's that's the score function
grading estimator this is a general
technique it can be used in various
machine learning problems now we're
going to apply it to the reinforcement
learning setting and we're going to take
our random variable X to be a whole
trajectory so the trajectory consists of
state action reward state action reward
and so on until the end of the episode
and now to get our gradient estimator to
get the do to get the gradient of the
expected reward all we've got to do is
compute the grad log probability times
the total reward so so this probability
of the trajectory that sounds like a
really unfriendly quantity because
there's a long complicated process that
generates this trajectory with lots of
lots of time steps but logged okay so we
can write out what this process is what
this probability density is so we have
it's just a product of probabilities
we've got our initials we've got our mu
if s 0 which is just our initial state
distribution and then every time step we
have we sample the action according to
PI and we sample the next state and
reward according to our dynamics model
so log turns that product into a sum and
here's the cool part everything that
doesn't contain theta drops out so the
thing is we didn't know there are parts
of this probability distribution P of
tau given theta that we don't have
access to so if this is reinforcement
learning we don't assume that we know
the dynamics model of the system we just
find out about it by sampling by doing
sample
doing episodes so nice so since this
product turns into a sum all the pieces
like the log log P there and the log mu
which we don't know just drop out so it
doesn't matter and what we get in the
end is we get a sum of log problem sum
of log probabilities of actions so grad
log PI of action given State so our
formula looks like our formula for the
grading of the expectation is just the
expectation over trajectories of total
reward of the trajectory times grad grad
of the sum of all the log probs so the
interpretation of this is we're taking
our good trajectories and we're trying
to increase their probability and
proportion to how good they are and you
can think of this as being similar to
supervised learning where we treat the
good trajectories with high rewards as
positive examples in our supervised
learning problem so we're using those to
train the policy on what which actions
are good we're basically treating those
actions as positive examples okay now we
can improve this formula a little bit so
that was just the most basic I mean this
is an unbiased estimator for the policy
gradient so if we just take that
expression inside the expectation on the
right hand side and we take one sample
of that it has the right mean so if we
just get enough of them we're going to
get the policy gradient okay so that's
but we can also write down some other
formulas that have the same mean but
have lower variance so we can come up
with better estimators for the policy
gradient and that's actually quite
important because the one from the
previous slide is really bad when you
have along a large number of time steps
meaning it has really high variance so
the first thing we can do is you we can
use the temporal structure of the
problem by the way
to derive these next bunch of formulas
it just takes a bunch of really
straightforward manipulation where you
move around expectations and I'm not
going to go through all the math but
I'll just say what the formulas are so
okay so we can repeat the same argument
from the previous slide to just derive
the grading estimator for a single
reward term so we end up with that
reward term times the grad sum of log
probs and just summing over that we get
a new formula where we're not
multiplying the sum of the the grad log
probable thing times the sum of all
rewards now so let's look at that bottom
formula now we have a sum over time of
grad log probability of the action at ty
at that time times the sum of future
rewards um so so now I mean in the
formula from the previous slide we would
have had all the rewards in that sum but
now we just have the future rewards and
that kind of makes sense because an
action can't affect the probability of
the previous rewards so to figure out if
the action is good we should have only
we should only be looking at the future
rewards so this is a slightly better
formula than the one on the previous
slide meaning it has the exact same mean
except different the expression inside
the expectation there has lower variance
and we can further reduce the variance
by introducing a baseline so now we can
take any old function B which takes in a
state and it outputs a real number and
we can subtract it from our sum of
future rewards and we didn't affect the
mean of the estimator at all so we yeah
we didn't change the expectation at all
by introducing this baseline so yeah for
any choice of B this gives us an
unbiased estimator by the way if you're
not that familiar with the terminology
of estimators what I'm saying is we have
a
expectation on the right hand side of
that for a formula and the quantity
inside that expectation is what's called
the estimator and if we get a bunch of
samples then we can get an estimate of
of the thing on the left-hand side which
is what we care about so so when I say
it's an unbiased estimator that just
means that well that just means that
this equation is correct meaning that
the thing on the right hand side equals
the thing on the left hand side so yeah
this works for any choice of baseline
and a near optimal choice is to use the
expected return so the expected sum of
future rewards and the interpretation of
that is if we took an action we only
want to increase the probability of the
action if it was a good action so how do
we tell if it was a good action well the
sum of her words after that action
should have been better than expected so
the B of S is the expected sum of
rewards and we're just taking the
difference between the measured thing
and the expect thing yeah okay so that's
okay that's the that was a pretty key
thing for variance reduction and I'm
going to introduce one last variance
reduction technique and actually all
three of these are really important so
basically nothing's going to work except
for maybe really small scale problems
unless you do these things so the last
variance reduction technique is to use
discounts so the discount factor ignores
delayed effects between actions and
rewards so what we're going to do here
looks kind of like a hack but there's an
explanation for it which is instead of
taking the sum of rewards we're going to
take a discounted summer of rewards
meaning that we we add this exponential
factor gamma so that when so when we're
multiplying the grad log probability by
some future award we multiply it by some
quantity that decays with time so people
typically use like
equals point 99 or gamma equals point 95
so that means like if you use point 99
that means after a hundred time steps
you're going to be you're going to be
reducing the reward by a factor of one
over e so so you're exponentially you're
decaying the effect of the future
rewards and the intuition is that an
action the action shouldn't affect
rewards really far in the future like
the system should this is this is like
the assumption is that the system
doesn't have really long term memory and
it's sort of reset sits or the there
aren't effect the effects aren't that
far delayed so you can just ignore the
interaction between action and a reward
way way in the future
that's the intuition so now instead of
taking the baseline to be the expected
sum of future rewards we want to do a
discounted sum so now we're measuring if
the action was better than expected
according to this like the according to
the discounted sum and now there's a
more general class of formulas that
looks like the one that I just wrote so
this this one that's on the top of the
slide is pretty good and this is like
almost as good as anything you're going
to do to within a small constant factor
but there's there's a more general class
of formulas that look like grad log
probability times some quantity a hat
which we call the advantage estimate and
this is in general just going to be an
estimate of this isn't it has a more
precise definition which is how much how
like how much was this action better
than the average action taken by the
policy but in but informally this just
means how much better was the action
than expected so and and this formula
makes a lot of sense because we want to
increase the probability of the good
actions and decrease the probability of
the bad ones
so we should we should increase it in
proportion to the goodness of the action
okay so just to summarize so I just told
you there's this gradient estimator
meaning there's this expression you can
compute which gives you a noisy estimate
of the policy gradient so how do you
actually turn this into an algorithm so
this is silly algorithm seven so so
here's what the algorithm looks like
it's pretty much what you'd expect you
you take your policy you initialize your
policy parameter and your baseline
function you for each each iteration you
execute the the current policy to get a
bunch of whole episodes meaning whole
trajectories and each time step in the
trajectory you should compute the return
meaning the sum of rewards following
that time step there's some of
discounted rewards and the advantage
estimate which is the sum of discounted
rewards minus the baseline then you
refit the baseline by trying to make the
baseline function equal of the returns
and then you update the policy using a
policy grading estimator so you're just
doing SGD while updating the baseline as
you go along
yeah so that's that's the vanilla policy
grading algorithm and this is I'll
briefly talk this has been used to
obtain some pretty good results so it's
not that bad of an algorithm but they're
there several different directions that
it can be improved so one one issue that
you run into is with step sizes so in
supervised learning step sizes aren't
that big of a deal because maybe you
take too big of a step but that's okay
you'll fix it the next update and your
current function your current classifier
for example doesn't affect what inputs
you're getting so even if you just are
doing really even if your network is
just kind of thrashing around for a
while because you're taking two big
steps that's not going to cause any
problems but
yeah and reinforced so yeah so step
sizes aren't that big of a deal you can
just anneal them you can start off with
a large step size and anneal them down
to zero and that works pretty well in
reinforcement learning if you take too
big of a step you might wreck your
policy and even if you don't actually
change the network that much so you
don't lose all your nice features you
you might just change its behavior a
little too much and now it's going to do
something totally different and visit a
totally different part of state space so
since in reinforcement learning the
system is stateful and your state
distribution depends on your policy that
makes that like brings a really a
different problem and now like after you
took that step the next batch of data
you're going to get was collected by the
bad policy and now you're never going to
recover because you just forgot
everything yeah so one way that my
colleagues and I well one way to fix
this is to try to to try to stop the
basically try to stop the policy from
taking too big a step so you can look at
the KL divergence between the old policy
and the new policy like before the
update and after the update and make
sure that the distributions aren't that
different so you're not taking too big
of a step it's kind of an obvious thing
to do so my colleagues and I developed
an algorithm called trust region policy
optimization which looks at the yeah it
looks at the action distributions and
tries to make sure the KL divergence
isn't too large and there's this is very
closely related to previous method
natura policy gradient methods which
which are based on which are doing is
something similar but usually it's not
set up as a hard constraint on the KL
divergence so another type of extension
of policy gradient methods is to do more
to use value value functions to do more
variance reduction instead of just using
them as a baseline you can also
you can use them more aggressively and
introduce some bias so I won't go into
the details in this talk but sometimes
these are called actor critic methods
there's also another type of approach
which I briefly touched on in the
earlier slide where instead of just
trying to increase the probability of
the good actions you actually
differentiate your loss with respect to
the actions this is like the Reaper
amortization trick which is used for
like for density modeling and
unsupervised learning so here you're
trying to instead of just increasing the
probability of the good actions you're
trying to push the actions towards
better actions and I'd say both of these
bullet points you're potentially
decreasing your variance a lot but at
the cost of increasing bias so it's
actually makes the algorithms a little
harder to like to understand and to get
them working because with high variance
if you just crank up the amount of data
you can always drive your variance down
as much as you want but with bias even
if no matter how much data you get
you're not going to get rid of the bias
so if you're grading is pointing in the
wrong direction then you're not going to
learn anything okay so now that that's
it for the policy gradient section of
this on this talk so I wanted to show a
quick video of some work that my
colleagues and I did on learning
locomotion controllers with policy
grading methods which I think well I
found pretty exciting when I saw it so
hopefully it's you find it interesting
so here what we've got is a humanoid
simulated let's see okay yeah it's a
simulated humanoid robot in a physics
simulator a realistic physics simulator
called macoco and it has a neural
network policy which takes in the joint
angles of the robot and maybe some and a
little bit of other kinematic
formation like joint has got joint
velocities and also positions of the
different links of the robot so that's
what the input is it's pretty much the
raw state of the robot like no clever
feature engineering there and the output
is going to be the joint torques which
are set a hundred times a second so
we're just mapping from joint angles to
joint torques and we define a reward
function which is to move forward as
fast as possible
so it gets a reward for moving forward
and it gets a so the episode ends when
it its head goes below a certain height
meaning it fell over so that's basically
the setup there was a little bit of
tweaking for the reward function but not
too extensive so oops
yeah so you can see first it just falls
forward a lot of times and then slowly
it starts to develop a half-decent
looking lock and eventually it gets it
down pretty well and at the very end of
this it could just keep running
indefinitely so I think it was actually
stable in a strong sense meaning I could
just leave it for 15 minutes and it
wouldn't fall over it would just keep
going so here's another robot model then
we just created without too much thought
I mean we just decided to put a bunch of
legs on this thing and so we don't even
know how this thing is supposed to walk
and just give it to the same algorithm
and it just figures out some kind of
crazy way to walk so that's the nice
thing about reinforcement learning you
don't even need to know what you want it
to do I think this is also the physics
are a little unrealistic here but here
we set up we use this a similar model to
the one in the first demo but here we
just give it a reward for having its
head at a certain height so there's the
word telling it to get its head up as
high as possible and then it figures out
how to get up off the ground
oh let's see and I have a low battery
does anyone have a charger that I could
thanks a lot your lifesaver okay any
questions about policy gradients before
I move on to the next part oh yeah so
the question was is the system time
invariant yes the that's that's assumed
is that it's stationary oh right and
also that it doesn't change from one
episode to the next of course in some
real-world problems that might not be
the case so that's I think that's also
an interesting problem setting where you
have a non stationary environment so the
question was for the baseline to learn a
good baseline do you need to know the
dynamics of the system so no you can
just learn it by doing regression you
just estimate the empirical returns and
then you do regression to try to fit a
function to that
yeah so the question is there's a
discount factor which causes the which
should cause the policy to disregard any
effects that are delayed by more than
100 time steps so how does it still work
that this guy learns how to stand up
even though that might take more than
100 time steps is that correct yeah so
yeah you're right
and in fact I would say that these
methods aren't guaranteed to work well
if you have more than 100 time steps so
sometimes they work anyway often they
work anyway but there's no guarantee so
I think there's actually something
pretty fundamental missing and how like
how to deal with really long timescales
and people have recently been thinking
about hierarchical reinforcement
learning where you have different levels
of detail of the system where you might
have a like one level of description
where you have a like a short time small
time step and then you have successively
larger time steps and you can that
allows you to plan over much longer
horizons so that's something that's
currently an active area of research but
yeah I would say that none of these
methods are going to do it are
guaranteed to do anything reasonable if
you have more than one over one minus
gamma time steps between action and
reward oh yeah so in this kind of task
if you introduced terrain or something
could I think if it didn't if you didn't
train it to deal with terrain then it
then it might fail it probably would
failed actually I don't think it would
fail because the funny thing about these
policies are actually really robust
because you train them with the
stochastic policy so there's a lot of
noise being generated by the policy
itself so in practice it's it's actually
so it's able to deal with huge noise
introduced by the policy and as a result
I found that if you change the dynamics
parameters a little it usually still
work but yeah there's no guarantee that
they'll do anything if you give it
something you didn't train it for I
think that you probably could train it
do the same kind of training with
terrain I didn't have any terrain so I
didn't try it but I'd be nice to try ok
I'm going to move on to the next part of
the talk feel free if you have more
questions to find me afterwards
okay so now I'm going to talk about a
different type of reinforcement learning
algorithm so okay so these so the
previous kind of methods are
distinguished by the fact that they
learn they explicitly represent a policy
which is the function that uses your
actions and they try to optimize it with
respect to the parameters of the policy
so the nice thing about the policy
grading methods we just talked about is
that you're optimizing the thing you
care about so and you're optimizing it
with gradient descent so that makes it
kind of easy to understand what's going
on because if you take if you're getting
the proper grading estimate and you take
small enough steps then you should be
improving I mean of course you still
could get stuck in a local minimum but
at least you get stuck in a bad local
minimum but at least it's a local
minimum and you can use the our
understanding of optimization to figure
out what's going on so these next class
of methods are a little different
because they're not optimizing the
policy directly they're learning
something else called the cue function
which measures how good state action
pairs are so it measures I'll say that
more formally late later but it's just
measuring how good the actions are and
these methods are actually the these are
able to exactly solve em DPS efficiently
in the setting where you have a finite
number of states and actions so these
are these are the preferred methods for
exactly solving them in those settings
but you can also apply them with
continuous States and actions and using
using expressive function approximator
is like neural networks but it's a
little harder to understand what's going
on in these methods like when they're
going to work and when they're not going
to work so I'll define the relevant
quantities here so the Q function is
defined as these expected sum of rewards
when we condition on the first state and
the first action so
we're conditioning on s0 equals s a0
equals a and we're we're and the Q
function is the expected discounted sum
of rewards when we're acting under the
policy PI so by convention I'm starting
out with time step 0 I could have also
said that we're taking RT plus RT plus 1
plus RT plus 2 and so on but since we're
assuming the system is stationary it
should be exactly the same so I'm just
by convention I'm going to say that the
first I'm going to always use time 0 1 2
3 and so on just for ease of notation so
the Q function is just telling you how
good in this state action para is under
your current policy the value function
well the state value function usually
called V is just conditioning on the
state it's telling you how good that
state is what's the expected reward at
that state and lastly there's an it the
advantage function is the difference
between the Q function in the state
value function meaning how much better
is that action than what the policy
would have done we're not going to talk
about advantage functions in this
section but it was actually this
corresponds to the notion of an
advantage estimator we briefly mentioned
in the previous section so here we're
going to consider methods that
explicitly store and update the Q
function instead of the policy and
updates them using what are called
bellman equations so so the bellman
equation so a bellman equation in
general is a consistency equation that
should be satisfied by a value function
so here I'm writing down the bellman
equation for Q PI and what it's saying
is that the expected sum of rewards
should be the first reward plus this
expected sum of rewards after the first
time step so it's saying something
pretty simple
that's so R 0 is the first reward
beep I of s1 is just adding up all the
rewards at after at after time step 0 so
in the second equation we write out this
relationship just involving the Q
function so we have a consistency
equation that the Q function should
satisfy we can slightly generalize this
to use K time steps instead of just one
time step so we can expand out the
expectation the expected sum of rewards
to write write out k rewards explicitly
and then cap it off with the value
function at the very end which accounts
for all the rewards after that okay so
here's the bellman equation from the
previous slide so now I'm going to
introduce a very important concept
called a bellman back up so so we have
this equation that the value the value
function Q PI should satisfy but we
don't know Q let's assume we don't know
Q PI so let's say we have some some
other Q function so we define this
bellman back up operator that that
operates on an arbitrary Q function so
an absolute Q function to a new Q
function and it's defined by just taking
the right-hand side of the bellman
equation and plugging in our Q function
our new Q function Q instead of the Q PI
so Q PI is a fixed point of this
operator meaning if we apply the backup
operator we get it the same thing back
and and very nicely if we keep applying
this backup operator repeatedly to any
old arbitrary initial Q function Q the
series will converge to Q Pi which is
the fixed point of the operator so
that's yeah so that's so that way you
can you can
one way you can use an iterative
algorithm to estimate q pi by taking any
old initial q function and repeatedly
applying this backup operator so now
there's another kind of q function that
we're going to introduce call it Q star
so the previous Q function q pi was this
is the telling you the value function
under the current under some policy pi
so it only makes sense with regard to
some particular fixed policy PI Q star
is going to be it is going to involve
the optimal policy instead so so Q star
is just defined as the q function of the
optimal policy so here we have PI star
the optimal policy and Q star is just
the q function of the optimal policy and
it also happens to be the point wise
maximum over all policies of the q
function at each state action pair so so
the optimal policy is deterministic and
it should satisfy this equation that it
takes the Arg max of the optimal q
function so recall that the Q function
tells you your expected return if you
take the given action so obviously the
optimal policy should take the action
that has the best expected return so
that's why that's why this last equation
is evident so so now now that we know
this property of the optimal policy we
can rewrite the bellman equation so so
on the first equation is that's just the
bellman equation from the previous
slides for a given policy PI now we can
take that expectation over actions and
replace it by what the optimal policy is
going to do which is just going to take
it's going to take the Arg max of the
optimal q function there's a typo on my
slide that should say Q star inside on
the right-hand side so so now we have a
bellman equation that the optimal policy
should satisfy
now we can do the same thing with a
backup operator so we we take that
bellman equation and we plug in an
arbitrary Q function on the right-hand
side instead of the optimal Q function Q
star so Q star is a fixed point of this
bellman operator that's just a
restatement of the bellman equation and
again if we reply this bellman operator
repeatedly to an arbitrary initial Q
function it converges to Q star which is
the optimal Q function this is the
binocs fixed point theorem in both cases
can be used to prove it okay so based on
these ideas there are two classic
algorithms for exactly solving MDPs
these are sometimes called dynamic
programming algorithms because they're
actually quite related to the kind of
dynamic programming algorithms that are
used to solve search problems so one is
called value iteration and you just
initialize your Q function arbitrarily
and you repeatedly do bellmen backups
until it converges now the second one is
called policy iteration you initialize
your policy arbitrarily then each step
you first can compute either exactly or
approximately the Q function of that
policy and then you update your policy
to be the greedy policy for the Q
function you just compute it so that
means that you your new policy just
takes the Arg max of the Q function so
it takes the action that's best
according to that Q function so I didn't
say anything about how you compute Q PI
so one way to do it is to compute it you
can compute it exactly because it
happens that the bellman equation for Q
Pi is a linear system of equations so
often you can just solve them exactly
more commonly well if you have a
large-scale problem you might not be
able to solve this system
so what people often do is they do a
finite number of bellman backups which
gives you which doesn't exactly converge
on Q pi but it gives you something
that's approximately q pi okay so that's
I just told you algorithms that you can
implement if you have full access to the
MDP like you know the whole table of
probabilities but in reinforcement
learning usually the assumption is that
you don't know any of these probability
distributions you don't know they're a
word function you don't know the
transition probabilities so all these
things have to be estimated from data or
they have to or you're only able to
access the system through interaction so
now it turns out that these algorithms
can be also implemented if you only
access the system through interactions
which is kind of remarkable I think um
so so the way it works is so let's
recall our backup formulas for Q PI and
Q star so we can so we can in both cases
we have this a certain quantity inside
and expectation in both both cases we
can compute an unbiased estimator of the
right of that quantity inside the
expectation just using a single sample
meaning if we have if we sampled some
data from our system using any old
policy then we can get an unbiased
estimator of the quantity on the right
hand side of those expectations I mean
the quantity on inside of the right hand
expectations so basically we can do an
approximate version of this bell minim
backup which is unbiased and even with
this noise so we're doing a noisy
version of the bellmen backup even with
this noise it can be proven that if you
do if you choose your step size
appropriately with the right schedule
you're still going to converge to q pi
or q star depending on which algorithm
you're implementing
okay so now well I'll say at this point
that this is pretty much the fundamental
idea and now you can you can come up
with algorithms that can be applied in
the reinforcement learning setting where
you're just accessing the system through
sampling and you can also start
introducing function approximation here
so in seventh said anything about what
the Q function is I've just told you
it's a function of state and action but
now we can start having neural network
cue functions for example so so we can
parametrize the Q function with the
neural network let's call it Q theta and
now instead of doing the bellmen backup
I mean it doesn't make sense to do the
bellmen backup exactly because we're not
just setting the values of the neural
network output the best we can do is try
to like encourage the neural network to
have some output values so what we do is
instead of doing the the way we do this
backup is we set up a least squares
problem so we write down this quadratic
objective that says that the Q function
should be approximately equal to the
backed up value and then we just
minimize it with SVD so one version of
this algorithm which was introduced
about ten years ago called neural fitted
Q iteration well it works exactly the
way you'd expect use sample trajectories
using your current policy which might be
determined by the Q function or it could
be any old policy as it turns out and
then you you solve the least squares
problem where you're trying to minimize
this quadratic you try to minimize this
quadratic error which is based on the
bellmen backup the backup for Q star so
one thing I haven't mentioned so far is
what do you actually use as your policy
so I said sample trajectory using your
policy so if you have a Q function you
can turn it into a policy by just taking
the action that has the highest Q value
that's what you typically do so the Q
function measures the goodness of
all your actions so you can easily turn
that into a policy by taking your best
action or by taking actions where the
log probability is proportional the
goodness or something like that so you
you might take typically probability as
is exponential of Q value over some kind
of temperature parameter that's called
Boltzmann exploration whereas if you use
just the greedy if you just take the Arg
max that's called the greedy policy so
it turns out that with these kind of Q
learning algorithms you don't have to
execute the greedy policy to for
learning to work there's you actually
have some freedom in what policy you can
execute which is actually one very nice
property of these algorithms that you
can use an exploration technique which
where your policy is actively trying to
reach new states or do something new and
still learn the correct still converge
still move towards Q star or q pi as the
case may be okay so that's so that's a
very basic neural fitted Q iteration is
sort of a basic way of doing this
a more recent algorithm that's gotten a
lot of attention is the one that was
from Mini at all from deep mind which is
basically an online version of this
algorithm with with a couple of useful
tweaks in it so and but actually when
you look at the two tricks they're
actually kind of very they make a lot of
sense if you just think about what value
iteration is doing so one one technique
is you use this replay pool where it's a
rolling history of your past data and
that's just the data you're going to use
to fit your Q function so that makes
sure you have like a representative
sample of data to fit your Q function to
and the second the second idea is to use
a target network so instead of using
your cute current Q function and just
doing bellmen backups on that you have
some lags version of your q function
so you have this target network which is
a copy of your cue function at some
earlier time and you use that in the
backups so that also if you think about
value iteration you're trying to you
have your old cue function and you're
trying to make the new one equal to the
backed up version of the old one so
using the target network just is sort of
the natural thing to do if you're trying
to implement value iteration in an
online way so and there have been many
extensions proposed since then I've got
a bunch of citations at the bottom of
the slide so this algorithm the dqn
algorithm is is using the backup B which
is the backup for Q star remember that I
also introduced this other backup B PI
which is the backup for Q PI so so
there's another algorithm like a very
classic algorithm called sarsa which is
an online way of doing the B PI backup
essentially well it's sort of an online
version of policy iteration but so it's
it's actually found to work as well or
better than DQ a well better than using
the B back up in some settings not all
settings so I think the jury's still out
on exactly how these things compare but
it's I think it's worth considering both
policy iteration and value iteration and
and all the different online versions
these algorithms and taking them
seriously because it's not clear right
now exactly which are how they all
compared each other in the function
approximation setting okay so that's
that's the overview of all the technical
parts and now I just have a couple
conclusion slides so so let me just
summarize the current state of affairs I
introduced two kinds of algorithms
policy grading algorithms which
explicitly represent a policy and
optimize it and Q function learning
algorithms which explicitly represent a
Q function which is the goodness of
different actions
and use that to implicitly represent a
policy so so policy grading methods
there's a lot of so there have been some
successes with different kinds different
variants of it so you have vanilla
policy grading methods there is a recent
paper on this a three C method which is
an async of implementation of it which
gets very good results there's also
another kind of methods are the natural
policy gradient methods trust reagent
methods so the video I showed you was
obtained using trust region policy
optimization which is one of these in
the second category so that makes it I
think these trust region methods net and
natural policy grading methods are more
sample efficient than the vanilla
methods because you end up you're doing
more than one grading update with each
little bit of data you collect so with
the vanilla policy gradient you just
compute one little grading estimate and
then you throw it away with natural
policy gradient you're solving a little
optimization problem with it so you get
more juice out of it so that's that's
what we have in the policy gradient
world and in the Q function world we
have the DQ n algorithm and some of its
relatives and these are sort of
descendants of value iteration where
you're approximating the bellmen back up
using value iteration and then sarsa is
also it's related to policy iteration
these are both different I mean these
are estimating different they're dealing
with different bellman equations so it's
kind of interesting that both kinds of
methods work and they all they're both
they have fairly similar behaviors as it
turns out so here's what I would say
that here's how I would compare them and
this is like anecdotal evidence but I
think this is the consensus right now
the q function methods are more sample
efficient when they work but they don't
work as generally as policy grading
methods
and it's a little harder to figure out
what's going on when they don't work and
that kind of makes sense because in the
policy gradient methods you're
optimizing exactly the thing you care
about with gradient descent
whereas with cue function methods you're
doing something indirect where your
Optima you're trying to learn a cue
function and then you're hoping that it
gives you a good policy and yeah so I
would also point out that there there
are also some confounds so it's hard to
make a good conclusion at this point
because people use different like time
horizons in the policy gradient methods
versus the cue function methods so they
do one step look Ahead's on the cue
functions and multi-step look Ahead's on
the policy gradients so it's not clear
if the extra if the differences come
from like using different time horizons
or some differences in how the
algorithms are working because you're
either doing regression for a cue
function versus learning a policy using
policy grades so just to summarize it I
would say here here are some of our core
model free reinforcement learning
algorithms and they are whoops I'm
missing a word in the first column which
I think should say wrote like
reliability and robustness so this just
means like is it going to work on new
problems without like without parameter
tuning or is it you're going to
mysteriously either work or not work so
this this would be my slightly sloppy
summary of all these different
algorithms I would say there's still
some room for improvement there might be
some improvements in the basic methods
because there are some nice properties
of the Q function methods that we don't
have in the policy gradient methods like
you can easily do off you can easily
explore with a different policy than the
one that you're learning the Q function
for and that's really important you
can't do that very easily with policy
gradient methods whereas the policy
grading methods just seem like they're
more you can just apply them in there
like more likely to work and it's well
understood what's
going on so I think yeah there's still I
don't know if it's possible to get the
best of both worlds but that's that's
the hope and that's it for my talk thank
you
any questions
oh yeah so in model-based reinforcement
learning what lines of research do I
find most interesting i think the work
for my colleagues on guided policy
search is very nice so i would say
that's the kind of model-based
reinforcement learning I also like there
are some methods that are using the
model for faster learning like for
variance reductions so there's a paper
called stochastic value gradients that I
like a lot I think it's a pretty wide
open area so I don't think there have
been a lot of really compelling results
where you're able to learn extremely
fast like you're able to learn with much
better sample efficiency using a model
so it seems like that should be possible
but I don't think it's been demonstrated
yet so maybe in the next couple years
we'll see that happen hello hi thanks
for the talk so I have a question is
that is it true or not true that most of
this problem requires some kind of
simulated well to to run experiments in
the episodes right oh yeah so are you
asking does this work in the real world
is that the question organs yeah I would
say it does work if you have a lot of
patients and you're willing to execute
this thing for a while so the locomotion
results I should add up to about two
weeks of real time so it's actually not
that bad especially when you consider
the babies toddlers take awhile to learn
how to walk properly
even though evolution already puts in a
lot of built-in information so I'd say
maybe yeah I'd say it's it can be run in
the real world some of my colleagues in
Berkeley are doing some experiments
where they are running just regular
reinforcement learning algorithms in the
real world very brave but I hope to see
some nice results from that soon thank
you
hi thanks for talking here on the other
side here I was wondering what was your
intuition on the lost surface of those
deep reinforcement learning optimization
problems and maybe especially how it
evolves in the from the as the policy
learns and I should specify in the
policy gradient case so I think the
situation is a little bit different in
reinforcement learning from a supervised
learning so in reinforcement learning
the loss you have you have one kind of
local minima in policy space so for
example let's say you want your so I'm
going to keep going back to the
locomotion example because I spent a lot
of time on it but let's say you want
your robot to walk there's one local
minimum where it just stands and it
doesn't bother to walk because there's
too much penalty for falling over and
there's another local minimum where it
just dives forward because it gets a
little bit of reward for that before it
falls to its doom so so even so I think
that that's actually the the hard part
about the like the optimization problem
is actually define is because of the
different space of behaviors and
actually has nothing to do with the
neural network so I've also found that
yeah it matters surprisingly little what
kind of architecture you use like what
kind of neural network architecture you
use because I think that most of the
hardness and the weirdness of the
problem comes from like what the
behavior space looks like rather than
what the actual numerical optimization
landscape looks like OOP thank you so
there are many problems where the reward
is only observed at the end of the task
so in the final in the terminal State in
each episode and you don't see rewards
and intermediate states so how much
harder to these problems become for deep
reinforcement learning experience Thanks
yeah so you have if you don't get the
reward until the end then then you can't
well then it's probably it might be
harder to learn yeah I I don't have
anything anything precise to say about
that I think it's going to be harder if
you have less if your rewards are
further away so for example for your in
your video for the last example of
getting up and getting the head above a
certain height yeah or example that
could be one where you only get a plus
one if you're above and you don't get
anything below all right doing something
that was kind of if you get your head
higher then you still get something
partial yeah so I think we came up with
a reward like distance from height
squared which made the problem easier
yeah the problem would have been a lot
harder if you get zero reward until you
get your head above the height um and
it's actually that would be a problem of
exploration which is that you have to
explore all the different states people
to figure out where you're going to get
good reward Thanks okay one last
question so I have a question about how
do you choose to quantize the space-time
because in your locomotion example you
clearly has the continuous system right
yeah so it's actually really important
how you discretize time like what time
step you use because if because the
algorithm has I mean the algorithm does
care about what the time step is so it's
not like yeah because you you have
discount factors and you're also
sampling a different action at every
time step so yeah so if you choose too
small of a time step then you then the
rewards will be delayed by more time
steps so that makes the like the credit
assignment harder and also your
exploration will be more like a random
walk because you're changing your minds
really frequently so yeah the time step
is pretty important and I'd say that's
that's a flaw in current methods okay
thank you
thank you so take a short break
reconvene in 15 minutes